>> SPEAKING OF THAT, CALLED HE
VANECEK, REBOUND IN BACK AND
NET AND THEN ALEX OVECHKIN RIGH0
GOALS IN NHLPPEN.
THEY'RE CERTAINLYEEPS MOVING TH
LEGS AND BINJURIES,
AND THEY HAVEN'T PLAYEDECONDS TT
ONMISHANDLES THAT AND
BACK TO THE FRONT IN BEHIND THE
NIGHT, McBAIN, TRIED TO POKE IT
HOME AND IT'S RIGHT THERE AGAINE
PAINT AND OUT THES ONE
WILL BE PLAYED BY HATHAWAY.
BIG HIT THTH BENCH
NOW CHEERING ON LARSSON.
TAKING IT AWAY, LARSSON WITH
THE LINE, WITH A BACKHANDER
RIGHT ON VEJMEME
ON
CORNER.
>> AND WHISTLED AS IT'S OUT OF
VEJMELKA.
THEY'RE GOING TO CLEAR AND
11:33 MARK AS THE CAPITALS
GET RIGHT TO THE ARIZONA
ONE WILL BE PLAYED BACK AND HE
BRINGS IT BACK cBAIN,'S GOT THE.
>>ND, A SHOT,
SCHULTZ, AND A REBOUND S SONE-TU
COULD HEAR IT UP OF A
SHOT OVER THE BLOCKER.
AND THE THE MIDDLE OF THEPOST.
AND ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY, CARLSON
RIGHT DOWN CHANGE IN
BETWEEN, TO OVER
VAN  ON THE
BENCH, TYSON?
THAT CAN'T HAD A CHANCE AND HIM
THERE'S NOND STOP GALCHENYUK.
AND COMES IN FRONT AGAIN! AND
BLOCKER OUT OF NOWHERE AND
ANOTHER ONE FOR OVECHKIN,
SHOTS, GLOVE SAVE VEJMELKA, A
HE'S BEEN OUT FOR SECOND EFFORT
BETWEEN HE AND
IN THE MIDDLE, IT'S UNDERNEATH
VANECE  JOHN CARLSON AND THA CA.
AND TRYING TO WORK IT TO